do you have that style icon I love Patti
Smith like the Patti Smith mixed in with
a bit of Audrey Hepburn it seems like
the odd combination but strangely you
can make it work
we've had several premieres so I've been
having to sort of jump into many a suit
I think what's amazing is you there are
brilliant people who work at these
fashion houses and they they have great
taste they go Eddy to try this I go okay
I sort of do what I'm told I work with a
stylist
Carla Welch and we work very closely
with each other and have lots of
conversations and it feels like a
collaboration do you have a favorite
city to live in I live in London I love
London
god I love Paris I love everywhere in
Italy one of the great things about my
job is the nomadic side of it so I love
being a traveler with it New York I just
moved there recently and I loved living
that is there anything you're obsessed
with right now that's all about the base
come on stop singing it's so addictive
it's like Pharrell so I'm happier just
like puts me in an instantly brilliant
move do you have a favorite comfort food
peanut butter sandwiches or Marmite on
toast with vices cucumber cheddar moment
so anyone who doesn't know it is it's
like you either love it or hate it very
weird English paste thing you have it
with cheddar and they're just delicious
if someone were to do a biopic on your
life could you think of a possible title
lots of hotel rooms aeroplanes in a
motel room who would you want to play it
they would never do it but they do them
two of my favorites
Andrew Garfield and Ben Whishaw so well
either those two I'd be very very
honoured made me